if you need the link to promote your
flyer for the course please let us know
we'll share with you when someone fills
out the form
we'll get another so transcriptomics one
the program will leverage online
materials that we offer for free which
you can sample and get a sense of the
content however the program will offer
greater detail and more focus on
practical application as well as provide
guidance and community to support your
learning inside the actual program as an
example let's start with transcriptomics
1 which is an introductory course for
next-generation sequencing data analysis
to study RNA expression let me show you
how the online courses are structured
when you first get to the page you'll
see that if you were logged in an
approved member of the program the
course will be free for those who are
not a part of the program the course is
paid and it actually requires a
membership
once you select take this course you'll
see that each course has an overview
video these are course topic overviews
and each they should be under 10 minutes
long online learning experience is
designed to track user activity as well
as help evaluate the efforts and the
practical steps that are going to be
taken these are visible to the students
which are you and then the program
members and faculty once you enroll in
the course you'll see the course
materials and these are organized in
course sections lessons quizzes and
assignments each course is going to have
a control section at the top these
include your profile link and then
points for your activities and they will
also display recent notifications if you
look at the top of the screen you'll see
the orange section of the control bar
you can find additional out i conce
these controls will simplify navigation
around the side and has helped you find
the relevant materials you need for each
lesson excuse me
the lessons on the site can be download
it is a full PDF and in these they'll be
available as an individual you know
session they have the same content as
the online material however when you're
online you get more interactivity
options you can track the course
progress each time you complete a lesson
and then this progress is going to be
updated as well as visible for you and
any faculty note that there's an online
glossary of terms throughout the lessons
and these will be hover over things that
you'll be able to read in addition to
the material that's inside the lesson
the course also includes practical
assignments that can help you practice
what you've learned these will be timed
but they have longer completion
timeframes they are scored and they will
include by practicing bioinformatics
analysis on our server the URL for that
server is server dot T - H bio info if
you need a link to that please let us
know and we will send out that in the
chat and it's important in each user you
need to have one for the educational
portal portal and then heading for the
analysis platform let me send you that
link real quick um it's going to be
server there you go okay so you need to
have a login for both the educational
portal portal as well as the platform
and then inside the course itself we are
going to explain the steps you'll need
to do in order to perform a demo
analysis in the assignments they have
you'll be running a full pipeline and
have to understand the outputs once you
complete your assignment you need to
submit it and it will upload to the site
and at this point you we will receive an
email with the details of that
submission
and then we'll evaluate those
assignments Holmes won't provide you the
profile where you can find your activity
and learning progress for each of your
courses you'll see submitted quizzes
assignments and the pipeline's that you
have completed after you've completed
the course your activities will be
graded and you'll receive a
certification if the criteria for that
is has been so let's talk a little bit
more about the Onix logic program in the
program we're gonna focus on one type of
data which is transcriptomics the
program is going to cover analysis of
gene expression data and it's going to
have practical sessions and online
tutorials if you have a basic knowledge
of cell and molecular biology you should
be able to conceptually understand and
then practically apply standard data
data analysis tools the goal here is to
process analyze interpret
complex transcriptomic data we'll be
doing so by leveraging regular online
webinars practical exercises and online
courses the resources are going to
provide a broad but yet detailed
overview of the processing statistical
analysis machine learning tools and
single cell data analysis techniques
we're going to cover methods expand on
various terminologies provide practical
examples and then we're gonna offer
quizzes so that you can evaluate your
progress in addition to the courses
you'll be getting access to hands-on
exercises these include data sets for
practice they can you completed without
any coding knowledge and you're gonna be
using our T bio info platform it
provides an interval interactive
learning experience the platform is
color coded and this is all done to
establish a logical connection between
theoretical aspects of data analysis
methods the practical steps needed are
going to be outlined to achieve a
biologically interpretive result
this is an example of one of the pop ups
that will occur during your experience
with the demo pop pipeline that's what
these are going to be offered as tables
graphics and interactive visualization
these are meant to help you understand
the way data can use to understand a
biological phenomena
this is an example and then here we'll
see how those linked to the genome so a
major topic of analysis of
transcriptomic data is the
identification of differentially
expressed expressed genes and isof worms
this is a straightforward approach that
allows us compare groups of samples
under different conditions we have to
make several considerations around this
data preparation such as normalization
and statistical adjustments and then in
this session this is where we're going
to expand on those methodologies the
online session will supplement
information that is offered in the
transcriptomics two modules it will
describe a number of statistical
techniques that are typically used for
simple and more complex approaches that
are going to be used for finding
differentially expressed genes I'm going
to go ahead and pass the presentation to
Elliott broadsky he's going to talk
briefly about the data science portion
of the program
eally are you there yes I am you have to
stop sharing for me to scratch ok great
can you see my screen game ok can you
see my screen I can alright great thank
you Joe so we will talk about several
data science aspects that have to do
with specific type of data that
sequencing produces for studying
expression of genes for example one of
the topics that we will focus on is how
to perform different transformations and
exploratory data analysis to the data
and understand how we can extract
relevant signal from the noisy data that
RNA sequence sense we talked about log
scale transformation we'll talk about
what what exactly it is and how does it
help us study our data and extract
better signals well also to talk about
how do you use different tools some of
them will be standard tools like
Microsoft Excel or SPSS and also our and
programming packages that will help us
extract the data and see better what we
can study now when we come to then
alysus of gene expression this session
will actually help us understand the
data as a whole and then to identify
specific types of patterns in our data
that are relevant to a phenotype so in
this section analysis of gene expression
will talk about unsupervised machine
learning so for example pc8 different
clustering techniques and we'll take a
look at how the clustering techniques
help us extract gene expression profiles
that can differentiate between different
samples when it comes to exploratory
data analysis tools like PCA or tease me
help us reduce dimensionality and focus
on the most informative properties of
the data for example with PCA will learn
about variance between samples and then
we'll talk about how we can explain this
variance using gene expression we'll
also talk about prints
for component analysis of the samples as
well as principal component analysis of
the individual genes to help us
understand gene properties as they show
us the variance between samples as a
result we'll take a look at the outputs
from principal component analysis under
different conditions
we'll use several examples to illustrate
how to interpret the variance between
samples so here you can see an example
using breast cancer cell lines that help
us differentiate between the different
subtypes of breast cancer then we'll
talk about data mining in more detail
when we talk about data mining we're
talking about having a large data set
and this large data set contains
thousands of genes and maybe hundreds of
samples and our objective is to mine
this high-throughput data this rich data
set to identify patterns that might be
interesting so machine learning
typically can be divided into supervised
and unsupervised and we will use both
techniques to first understand the data
but then also to classify the data based
on some understanding of the data for
example if we found a number of
different subtypes of breast cancer for
example there are four or five and
different methods identify different
subtypes then we can use that to for
example train our model using decision
trees or a random forest and other types
of classification tools and also we'll
talk about different issues that come up
issues of representing and
generalizability of the models that we
train so here you can see an example of
a gene profile that displays a certain
pattern and the question will be well in
this example how can we differentiate
between for example basal cloud and low
luminal and other types of breast
cancers that we are studying and as an
example we will leverage some of these
classification techniques to explore
more in depth the other types of
classification tools like discriminant
analysis and support vector machines
that can help us
make better classification better
quality or better accuracy of
classification using higher
dimensionality at the same time we can
use feature selection as a part of for
example random forests whether we can
evaluate feature selection in a
step-by-step manner and then we can
identify those features that are most
useful for separation between the
classes that we have been using and that
will increase the efficiency of our
model prediction and accuracy of the
model prediction but also it is going to
be used for visualization but at the end
we're not talking about just statistical
analysis we're actually talking about
biologically interoperable results and
for us to be able to interpret the
biological meaning of the data and of
the different features of the data that
we're studying we have to be able to
annotate the genes that we found and the
gene sets and associate them with gene
function protein function the genes
encode for protein so we have to look at
gene oncology's as well as pathway
analysis and also how the statistical
significance of pathway enrichment can
help us identify not only a
statistically significant biomarkers but
also biologically meaningful biomarkers
so for that we'll try and use gene set
and pathway enrichment using pathway
enrichment analysis using pathways that
are found on CAG so here you can see
differential expression the genes that
are upregulated are in the red the genes
that are down regulated are in the red
in the green and you can see it mapped
on a pathway that is statistically
significant because it is enriched with
genes found in the data set single cell
transcriptomics is a big kind of
emerging aspect of RNA seek up until now
we've been talking about bulk RNA
sequencing when we sequence a whole
sample that might contain
a number of different in cell types for
example when you capture a tumor within
that tumor what's called tumor
heterogeneity you have maybe some
metastatic cells maybe these stem cells
that are not gonna static you might
capture epithelial cells and and other
types of themselves
you might even capture some of the micro
environment but when you're studying the
whole the bulk of that data you're
extracting the most prominent signal at
the same time when you are able to
separate those cells into different
subtypes you might get a much better
understanding for example of a
proportion of how many metastatic versus
how many non-metastatic how different
variation in cell and gene expression
within those cells can play a role in
your ability to for example diagnose or
prescribe certain treatments so we'll
talk about different types of single
cell transplant tonic techniques which
by the way over the years have emerged
and and now we have quite a number of
different techniques for single cell
sequencing now single cell data is very
different from bulk RNA sequencing we
talk about separating cells into
different types of cells but we also
talk about different ways of looking at
the data which is what's called 0
inflated and has a lot of zeros and very
noisy because we have low coverage for
different types of cells so instead of
bulk RNA where we have PCR amplification
that helps us study the most prominent
expression levels here we have to deal
with non amplified and low signal and
still extracts a meaningful population
data for this type of sequencing at the
end of the program one of our focuses is
to allow independent project work so
after you've learned how to practically
analyze the data how to look at
different types of data bulk RNA single
cell and other non-coding poly a
non-police or different
types of RNA seek data you'll be able to
select the project from one of the
projects that we offer or propose a
project of your own following some
project preparation process that will
help you get the most out of the project
we've prepared a number of projects that
you can start with that cover different
types of next generation sequencing
aspects from cancer to bacterial
infections to viral and even rise in
bacteria so we'll take a look at
different examples and we'll provide you
with guides and you will be able to
either work with one of our mentors or
you'll be able to work as groups as a
part of the program and we'll guide you
step-by-step on how to select the data
to prepare the data for analysis
structure the data so it's ready to be
analyzed and then ask the right
questions questions that will mean
something significant something
different from what's already been done
and then to of course
present your results either to your
peers or at a conference or at a poster
session that you might have access to so
working on a project is important
because you'll understand the details of
the methods that we reviewed you really
see how they play out in a real setting
when you have to deal with the real data
set and you'll be able to see how to
apply RNA seek not to any data set but a
data set that you're interested in a
data set that you have found to be
engaging for you and for your community
we also have examples of students
working together so here you can see a
group of students that we've been
working with a Loyola University that
went through the program that we
described here and apply these
techniques to a data set that their
professor has selected for them and then
presenting those results to the peers
obviously people will start asking
questions you have to respond to those
questions so that allows you to really
prepare and think through the reason why
you selected certain steps and what is
the outcome in terms of its biological
need
in the past students that have
participated in our programs have went
on and presented their results at
different conferences and poster
sessions and have gotten have gotten
their posters into conferences on
bioinformatics neuroscience and other
types of research we do have a lot of
participants that have finished programs
in the past we don't only do programs on
transcriptomics there is a variety of
Onyx logic programs that we conduct
throughout the year and students at an
undergraduate graduate level but also
faculty have joined these programs in
the past and have found the materials
that we prepared to be both
comprehensive and engaging both for
students for faculty and for researchers
so we don't narrow the target audience
here to be just undergraduate students
we think that anyone with an interest in
RNA seek in analyzing data and
interpreting that data can benefit from
the program because the program is
structured both by online self-guided
materials that Joe explained very well
in the beginning and interactive
sessions like this one where we go
through and guide people to use
different methods you will be able to
both gain a practical skill of analyzing
data and a theoretical more research
kind of overview of the different
methods that are typically used for the
analysis as well as the different types
of projects where our NAC could be a
useful technique so we encourage you to
explore the program the program is going
to be the program is going to be
starting in January let me just go here
quickly to the link so the link can be
found right here I'm going to just pay
in chat for anyone that would like to
join and here you'll be able to see some
overview of the program topics that are
covered there's a video that describes
the topics in greater detail a schedule
starting from January 14th which is next
week and here at the end if you are
interested you can fill out this form
and submit it and after you fill out
this form you will be directed to
complete your registration so to
complete your registration what Joe
showed in the beginning you will see
some of the online course materials that
we have and also the platform that we
will use to analyze this data so just to
briefly show you what the platform
includes and how it is used I'm going to
switch over to the screen once you have
your account you can by the way request
a demo account to see some of the
elements that we have here we have a
whole section on next-generation
sequencing data that includes
transcriptomics genomics epigenetics and
other types of data including
metagenomics but we also offer sections
on mass spectrum spectroscopy structural
biology data integration and modeling
and then a lot of different tools on
data Association and data mining and
we're always developing new sections and
right now we have a section on biology
cancer biology and biology of Aging and
those are in development by using the
platform in the courses in the course
and the practical sessions you will be
able to try out different types of
approaches for example for RNA seek for
transcriptomics we will use a couple of
projects one on cell line projects where
we have a collection of different cell
lines from different types of breast
cancers and we have a PDA exa
patient-derived xenograft model project
that you can play around with and
understand the data so we explained here
every step
and we also provide the technical
description of the methods as you will
see in the following steps
a typical RNA seek pipeline a processing
pipeline will include several major
steps like pre-processing where we have
to trim the adapters and remove the PCR
amplification and then we can map our
data using a variety of mappers hice at
bowtie and others after that we have to
quantify the data and for quantification
there are also a number of different
techniques so for example using HTC and
once you prepare this pipeline you can
quickly see the results and so once you
see the results once you understand what
the results look like now you are ready
to use the platform without a demo once
you are ready for that process you'll be
able to upload a data set and here you
have to make some choices for example
the PDX project is a pair end project
with fast queue files and you can map it
on both the human and the mouse genome
once you upload the data you will be
given the data set that you will pass
here here you can add more and now you
have to do the same steps to actually
run that analysis on the data that you
prepared you can of course select the
most appropriate type of analysis for
what you need in downstream steps after
you have prepared your pipeline you'll
be able to save the pipeline
and run it in some cases you would want
to transfer the analysis from the
platform out of the platform and do it
in R or Excel or other types of
environments what you can do for example
is analyze the data a lot of the
techniques right here that do
statistical analysis annotation and data
mining techniques they will provide you
with an output file that actually starts
with a script and then on the platform
on the educational portal you'll be able
to take that script and go through steps
to modify the script to for example
produce a visualization that is more
informative and more relevant to the
type of analysis that you have done so
just an example of one of the courses
that does that is going to take the
output from principal component analysis
and guide you through the steps of how
to modify the script and arm and produce
a different type of visualization so
here you will learn about our coding
environment and how to use the standard
output of that script and then also how
to modify that to improve the clustering
and visualization and make the
visualization more informative so
briefly this is an overview of the
program the topics like I mentioned are
going to be available right here where
you can see the different sessions that
we are planning and the topics that are
going to be covered we hope that you can
join us and go through some of these
materials together with Joe Mohit and
myself will be taking different sections
to talk about different parts of the
program and I'm happy to answer any
other questions that you might have
either about the program about the
platform or about RNA secrets itself and
transcriptome data analysis
you
you request participants to unmute
themselves and ask questions regarding
the presentation that we've been through
and regarding the courses or the
registration details
I do I I do by the way I want to just
mention briefly that we have a in
parallel a number of programs that are
going to be happening at the same time
and we know that you probably saw
different types of emails and
announcements that we've done so I do
want to just clarify what the
differences might be we will have this
program is focused on independent
research projects and helping you
understand RNA steek but it's for an
online audience there's not going to be
a physical place where we meet it's just
fully gonna be online using zoom like
today at the end of the program you will
be able to receive the recording there
are other programs that are going to be
available locally for example we have a
program that's going to start at image
University in Kolkata in India so anyone
who is in India and primarily this is
for students from MIT University there
but I believe others might be able to
join that as well you should learn the
same elements of the program that we are
talking about today but in that program
and then we have a course that is a
graduate course at LSU and this is in
Louisiana and this is sponsored by the
Louisiana biomedical research network so
if you're a part of any campuses of LSU
or any other universities in Louisiana
and you would like to join that course
that would be a better course for you to
join because it will have sessions that
are on-site and they provide you QA and
interaction with faculty from LSU and
from the Louisiana biomedical research
Network there's also a program at
Georgetown University in Washington DC
that will cover aspects of next
generation C
in data analysis for genomic data and
transcriptomic data so if you're in DC
and you want to learn about those you
can reach out to us about that one as
well and then we of course have programs
that are not just focused on RNA seek
they're focused on many other types of
data for example genomic data
transcriptomic data metagenomic data
epigenomic data and others and after
this program starts we will start
sending announcements and posting them
on this site as soon as we have the
dates and the topics confirmed which is
probably going to start after the 15th
of January so please make sure that
you're following those updates as well
okay so
why are we going to use our and not
Python yes it's true that python is
often used for data science and machine
learning but in our there are a lot of
packages that make it easier for
biologists to use a single package that
does many things statistical analysis
and notation visualization etc so that's
why these programs are actually
primarily focused on people that have a
background in life sciences so they
probably already understand some of the
biological background of the project and
they don't have a lot of experience
using coding Python does require a
little more background in coding and a
lot more background in biostatistics or
machine learning and that's just a lot
to combine in a single program in the
future we hope to offer a lot of the
same elements using Python as well but
this specific program is going to
include just elements of R and a lot of
those that are going to be optional so
you can conduct all of the analyses that
we will discuss not doing any coding at
all but you will have a chance to try
some of the packages right and packages
here's keyword because bioinformatics
packages are abundant in R and for
Python of course you have bio Python but
it's not as easy to just get started
okay
independent research project can be used
for further research I mean how much
authentic this independent research can
it be presented as evidence for further
research in Research Institute
definitely yes so you know as I showed
before we had a number of groups and
maybe I can just you know point out some
of those projects that were done we had
a whole team of students international
students one of them was from the US one
of them was from Germany and a number of
them were from India and Pakistan and
they worked together on a project on
Alzheimer's disease they also did a
project on neuro degeneration at the
basic biology of neuro degeneration by
looking at different types of neuronal
cells and then they presented their
poster at the annual bioinformatics
research conference in at Louisiana
State University we also had a student
from Israel that did her work on on a
genetic disease that leads also to neuro
degeneration so this was a neuroscience
program and she went on to do her PhD
using that data set we also had students
from Tulane University that worked with
their faculty and like I mentioned we
had students from Loyola University
where they worked on on a project with
arthritis theta and later on the faculty
member actually took a sabbatical and
continued working with that dataset in
her sabbatical so I think that you know
it obviously depends on where you are
now and how how much clarity you have on
the data set that you have chosen to
work on and who is going to be your
partner but that's what we hope to
achieve with this program with this
program in the past we've had very good
interaction between students and faculty
actually the professor from Tulane
University Ian Townley ended up working
with a partner from the UK to analyze
some of the data that he had sitting
from his lab so I think a lot of this
actually leads to
search projects and and the research
projects are going to be you know
informative for for research discussions
as you plan your analysis further your
from plant biology background is there
hard core mathematics to understand so
we try to avoid formulas as much as
possible but when we do speak about
formulas because you know they're hard
to avoid we do explain them in language
that I think biologists can understand
and we try to find examples that clarify
the mathematics behind it I don't think
that you need hardcore mathematics or
biostatistics to take this course and
get something out of it for those of you
that have a plant biology background I
suggest to take a look at one of the
projects that we have which is actually
on the impact of a draw drought stress
on potatoes so you can find this project
right here of course right here it's
it's mentioned as paid if you're a part
of the program it's going to be
accessible to you as well but what I'm
trying to say is that I already have
examples of projects and by the way this
project was prepared also by a student
the student was from University of
Nebraska Omaha where they study a lot of
plant biology as well but these types of
projects are also using a lot of RNA
seek to understand the molecular
regulation of different stress response
and there's a lot of other topics as
well in plant biology that I think could
be relevant to your research
okay if you have any other questions
again you can an ND team if you can let
me know if that clarifies your question
I can clarify more if needed and if
anyone else needs if anyone else has any
questions you can go ahead and mute
yourself or even paste it in the chat
let the other stood are there
today classes so what I suggest to
understand the program schedule is to
look right here on this link you have
the list of sessions that we have as you
can see there every several every you
know once every few days they're not
going to be every day and the sessions
are all going to be at the same time
online and if you can't make one of the
sessions you will be able to get a
recorded session and then participate in
the discussion for example post your
questions on a forum or even schedule a
meeting with one of the trainers online
you
okay yeah I think you will a similar
program like this be available in the
fall so Tara I I don't know you know
which university you're from so we do
have a schedule for online programs
throughout the summer and in the fall so
definitely yes online you'll have those
but if you are in you know one of the
areas where we have a collaboration with
a university like if you're in Louisiana
if you're in the you know around DC area
or other areas that we have something
going on I'd be happy to connect you
with those programs can you let me know
what university you're in
kara okay great so for Louisiana
University so Southeastern Louisiana
University is a part of they'll be Iran
and they will have an undergraduate
course starting in the fall they will
also have a summer course and depending
on your level we have an undergraduate
course or there will also be a graduate
course that will be handled by l.b RN
and available online to all the lbm
campuses so if you write us I'll be
happy to connect you with write
information on that and and what I also
would suggest is looking at this link so
this is these are the programs that we
run for the Louisiana biomedical
research Network it's focused on
Louisiana universities and campuses and
here is the upcoming LP I ran
transcriptomics program it's a very
similar program but it's a graduate
course undergraduate students can also
join this but of course you're asking
about the fall program so after this
program is over you'll be able to see
details for the summer and the fall
programs juris one sec so let me just
paste this for Tara so you can take a
look at that what can you recommend for
someone who is coming from a pure
computer science background ten years of
professional programming some biology do
you think your platform can provide that
introduction to the biologist part of my
informatics do you think your platform
can provide that introduction to the
biology protocol and format okay so yes
I think that that's a major challenge
for computer science you know people
students researchers etcetera
you probably have a lot of technical
know-how
and familiar with a lot of different
approaches but one of the major
questions is okay how do I select the
project that is going to be meaningful
for me how do I conduct the analysis in
such a way that I don't get some
interesting patterns but I can also
interpret the patents and then finally
when I interpret those patterns how do I
pick some kind of a topic that is going
to be impactful and interesting and that
is a big part of the program that we try
to incorporate into the sessions but
also into that portion on the
independent analysis the platform itself
the the reason why this platform is
useful for someone that knows how to
code isn't just the coding part right so
bioinformatics is much more than coding
man from magic man from attics is
critical thinking is understanding what
kind of methods are going to be
appropriate for what kind of data and
then finally how do you can combine
those methods and the biology to make
something meaningful
so the transcriptomics program will
start off by explaining the biology of
RNA transcription and it's going to talk
about alternative splicing it's going to
talk about how that plays a role in a
variety of pathologies and different
projects for example how is it different
for cancer how is it different for
viruses how is it different for plants
right you have to understand some of
those basic things then after you
understand that
you have to also understand the
properties of the data itself when we
talked about RNA seek data these are
short reads mapped on to genomes genomes
have a certain structure and when we try
to assess the level of expression we
have to understand what those numbers
mean after we have those numbers there's
certain certain transformations that we
have to do we have to for example do log
normal transformation we have to look at
the distribution we have to then analyze
that normalized data so those things
will play a big role in how we interpret
the results for example what is a high
enough level of expression
when we talk about log fpkm values why
do we use fpkm when we do pca
and why do we use raw count when we do
differential gene expression those are
questions that have to do with both the
data signing of things but also have to
do with the biology data with the
biology side of things you know when you
do folks change what is the meaningful
phone change
meaningful for what right so all of
those questions are the questions that
we will try to answer in the program yes
I definitely recommend going through
some materials that will give you a
background and what I recommend are you
know again what we try to prepare on our
end are some of these free resources
right so a lot of people ask us why do
you offer a lot of these materials
online for free but then you have these
programs you know online materials what
a lot of you probably know is you try to
take a course you kind of understand ten
fifteen twenty five percent of the
course but you completed it right you're
not gonna go back and review all the
details the program helps overcome that
because you have a guide you have
someone that takes you through the steps
one by one making sure that you
understand them and you can apply them
and you have somebody to talk to you
have somebody to ask questions them so
what I recommend is going through
introduction to my informatics that will
provide you with some overview of
important concepts and important
directions where bioinformatics plays a
major role in discovery and in research
transcriptomics one in my opinion is a
fairly basic level that describes some
of the elements of what we talked about
today and we'll provide you with a
review that will you know explain to you
what our genes explain to you water as
it forms where exons introns different
genomes and things like that there's
also a great course called introduction
to genomics right here that talks about
some of the next-generation sequencing
techniques the DNA kind of gives you a
sense of some of the terminology what
are nucleotides etc so I recommend
these things that we offer there's also
a lot of material online elsewhere so
obviously there are courses on Coursera
on EDX on other platforms that talk in
general terms about molecular biology
which i think coming from a CS
background you would probably benefit
from
thank you very much are there any other
questions that we can address today
well what program would be best for
someone with a strong background biology
and with what lab experience but with no
experience in bioinformatics so again
just getting started I would recommend
taking this course it's a free course
called introduction to bioinformatics
and bioinformatics
is a term that is often misused
bioinformatics has gone through a lot of
transformation over the past several
years when we you know heard the word
vile informatics probably five or six
for ten years ago you would think
sequence alignment you would think you
know how to search for blasts how to do
blast searches how to you know used the
site NCBI that was by informatics back
banking today bioinformatics is big data
science its stated driven research it's
how do I come to my research question
from a different data driven perspective
how do i leverage these large
collections of data sets like the Cancer
Genome Atlas or you know a thousand
genomes or other repositories that I
have to just understand what they are to
be able to leverage them and also a good
understanding of data science tools how
do I do exploratory data analysis how do
I do machine learning how do I train
models how to evaluate the training of
models right so that transformation I
think is important for anyone that is
now involved in life science research
because ultimately when you do the
experiment in the lab it plays a role in
your experiment design it plays a role
in what type of data you want to collect
being knowledgeable about what the
output of analysis would be to
understand statistical significance how
many samples new you need what kind of
conditions can you you know control and
and you can't control right so those
things play a big role and they're all
related to bioinformatics
so this course goes over some of that
material data-driven discovery real-life
examples in healthcare
personalized medicine molecular
diagnostics treatment development as
well as some of the other topics that
are covered right here I think that and
Joe can probably add to this coming from
biochemistry background you know the
materials that we have in
transcriptomics one in in all of the
basic courses so transcriptomics one
metagenomics wonjun onyx one and there
are some others will be interesting
enough for you to kind of see how the
tools are useful and meaningful in your
type of research of course I would have
to know a little bit more about your
background in the wet lab maybe you can
post it on chat you know and and we can
suggest some other materials that might
be interesting you're useful to you I
would also say that you know not
everything is a course on the basics
there are some projects here that you
can scroll through some of them are
fully available online others we use in
programs like this they're not fully
available but they span a variety of
different topics and you know the more
we know about you the better we can help
you yes and thank you Joe for pointing
that out
what we try to do and maybe I'll just
show you a couple of things we have over
2000 participants on the platform and we
try to try to use our point system to
show kind of who's who and and I think
it's very nice to understand you know
what other people are on this platform
and where are they and what do they do
so you can go to this link and see some
of the top profiles that we have just to
kind of understand who they are and see
where they are from and what is their
background so you can
I click on any one of these profiles and
obviously see little information about
that person Sarah
for example joined already the the
transcriptomics upcoming program you can
see her activity you can see her profile
she's from International University in
Florida she's interested in forensic
science and has some background
biomedical sciences so you also if you
add your social media links obviously
people can connect you know you can go
and see their LinkedIn for example and
connect with them and I think that's
really a big part of this program is you
also get to know a lot of people that
are have similar interests that are also
trying to develop their career and build
up their resume using you know some of
the materials that we offer and and you
can you can see their profiles and kind
of learn more about these people and you
know connect with them further okay well
again it's great to meet all of you
those that had questions I hope that I
was able to answer to some of the
questions if you have any other
questions about other programs or other
resources that we offer please ask us
Rocio sorry I just saw the message
you're working on cancer by including
and analyzing intensely relevant
mutations and developmental biology by
developing animal models to question the
relevance of some genetic development
sort of survival and differentiation
modernity or cell populations yeah you
know I mean honestly I think that a lot
of the things that you're describing
here we're going to be in this program
will be going through RNA seek for
cancer diagnostics so how can you
diagnose a specific subtype of cancer
we'll be talking about differential gene
expression for example the difference
between metastatic and non metastatic
cancer we'll be talking about you know
single cell data which
you also seem to be interested in so I
think that you you know you will
definitely benefit from the program that
we have and we have quite a number of
projects in cancer starting from cell
lines to internal models to patient
samples so I encourage you to try and
join if you can if you can't then at
least take some of the free courses
online
Duras yes the certificates so again it
depends on where you are
where are you juris sorry which you know
geography where are you are you in
Europe are you in the US
and I will just mention this briefly in
London okay so if you're moving to the
US employers in the u.s. obviously we
will look at you the basic background
you know see us biology whatever but
primarily they will also ask you about
projects and that's a huge part of the
interview process you know having a CS
background it's great data Sciences as
you know becoming a very hot topic
everywhere but data science is different
from bioinformatics and data science
from scene learning in bioinformatics is
a an extremely high growing area you
know where you have to differentiate
yourself right you have to be able to
say what is it that you did with the
tools that you know how to use what
problems have you been able to solve and
that's what this program is going to be
designed around right you will get a
certificate and certificate is okay but
when they will ask you what projects did
you work on and you are able to think
through okay what is the data how much
data analyze that in a short period of
time if you're gonna be looking for a
job and you want to focus on
personalized medicine or neuroscience
research or some kind of a multi-omics
integration you're using deep learning
who's to learning I mean those are the
kinds of things that are going to stand
out to your employer potential employer
I recommend RNA seek because that will
start from kind of a more basic level
and get you all the way through to
single cell but then in the future what
I would also recommend we don't have but
right now but we will have another
program called data science for
biomedical data and that's more of a
data science application how do you
apply it to solve some of these hot
topic problems that are relevant to you
know pharmaceutical companies clinical
research organizations research centers
and you know we we also regularly and
I'd be happy to add you to our LinkedIn
group we regularly post some of those
job opportunities and research
opportunities in our LinkedIn group so
if you're interested you
able to apply for jobs there of course
we don't do you know job placement but
these are just guidelines and
suggestions from our side alright great
thank you everyone for joining today it
was great to meet you again we sent you
the links in the chat we will follow up
with you how frequently can we interact
with the project supervisor doing
working on the project where a guideline
so we do require from you to get to a
certain level before you start
interacting with supervisor essentially
you have to complete several of the
online courses and you have to start
practicing some pipelines to just
understand what is the data and what are
you trying to do then there will be a
form that you have to fill out and we'll
guide you about selecting the project
data set planning your analysis thinking
through the question that you're trying
to ask
etc after we get that we will reach out
to you and schedule between 3 and 5
meetings that will either be as a group
or one-on-one to discuss the details of
the project alright great thank you
everyone will send the recording after
we end here and great to meet you again
and hope to see you as a part of the
program take care